die drei kleinen breaking news denn
dieser Hubschrauber landet gerade in
Karlsruhe beim Generalbundesanwalt es
geht um den irren und gefährlichen
entführungsplan von Karl Lauterbach also
es ging um eine geplante Entführung des
Bundesgesundheitsministerin Ministers
und die rädelsführerin in diesem Fall
die soll jetzt gefasst sein ja Elisabeth
R aus Sachsen ja das ist eine
reichsbürgerin offensichtlich und sie
soll eben wie gesagt die regelsführerin
einer ganzen Gruppe von reichsbürgern
und Querdenkern gewesen sein die eben
Karl Lauterbach entführen wollten aber
nicht nur das sie wollten auch ja Terror
verbreiten sie wollten die
Bundesregierung stürzen
bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände
herbeiführen heißt es wir haben
inzwischen wissen wir auch so ein
bisschen mehr über Elisabeth R sie
verfolge eben eine Ideologie nach der
die auf dem Grundgesetz berunde
staatliche Grundordnung der
Bundesrepublik keine Geltung
beanspruchen kann heißt es speziell für
sie existiert offenbar noch das Deutsche
Reich auf Grundlage der Verfassung von
1871 das waren über Plan Operation
Klabautermann hat diese Gruppe sich
genannt das war so eine Mischung eben
aus reichsbürgern und Querdenkern und
die wollten den
Bundesgesundheitsminister entführen
haben das über mehrere Bundesländer
gemacht das spielte vor allen Dingen im
Saarland und in Rheinland-Pfalz und eben
dort jetzt ganz offenbar auch in Sachsen
es wurde sich schon umgeschaut nach
Waffen es gab diesen konkreten Plan und
seit dem Frühjahr sitzen schon vier
Männer dieser Gruppe in
Untersuchungshaft und man hat immer noch
gesucht Wer ist das fünfte Mitglied
dieser Gruppe man hat diese Frau gesucht
und jetzt ganz offenbar dann gefunden
sie also dort so heißt es jetzt in
diesem Hubschrauber und soll dann heute
noch da den Bundesrichter vorgeführt
werden ja jetzt warten wir eben auf den
Moment dass Elisabeth r die
reichsbürgerin die regelsführerin dieser
Gruppe tatsächlich diesen Hubschrauber
verlässt dass einen Blick auf sie werfen
können gerade eben erst gelandet dieser
Polizeihubschrauber eben in Karlsruhe
und jetzt scheint es eben auch so weit
zu sein dass Elisabeth R gleich den
Hubschrauber verlassen wird und dann
wird sie jetzt gerade gesagt eben dann
auch noch dem Ermittlungsrichter
vorgeführt ich habe ja immer wieder
Morddrohungen gegen Karl Lauterbach Hass
im Netz und hier geht es aber
tatsächlich um eine geplante Terror tat
das geht noch mal weit über das hinaus
und eben seit dem Frühjahr dort flog
dieser Plan auf dann vier Männer sofort
in Untersuchungshaft genommen dort
sitzen sie auch weiter und dann danach
die Suche nach einem weiteren Mitglied
dieser Terrorgruppe die sich über Terror
telegram dort zusammengewürfelt hatte
Querdenker und Reichsbürger und jetzt
offenbar erst mal der größte Erfolg in
diesen Ermittlungen für die Polizei und
Ermittlungsbehörden der
Generalbundesanwalt hat damals sehr sehr
früh die Ermittlungen übernommen weil
sofort hier geht es um eine
staatsgefährdende Tat hier geht's um die
Entführung eines Bundesministers und
noch um mehr es geht tatsächlich um den
Plan des Umsturzes der Demokratie hier
in Deutschland einen Plan von
reichsbürgern eben ja und jetzt also
Elisabeth r die mutmaßliche
regelsführerin dieser Gruppierung
gefasst und sie wird jetzt in diesem
Moment eben in Karlsruhe in diesem
Hubschrauber man kann nicht genau
erkennen was er jetzt noch passiert vor
wenigen Minuten ja gelandet gerade der
Hubschrauber wird sie eben jetzt dem
Ermittlungsrichter dem Haftrichter
vorgeführt und höchstwahrscheinlich wird
sie dann eben auch in Untersuchungshaft
verbracht wo eben auch schon kai hat
gesagt die vier anderen mutmaßlichen
Terroristen sitzen Lauterbach selbst hat
sich ja zu dem Thema der Bedrohung auch
immer wieder geäußert er hat dann auch
selbst immer wieder Videos gemacht aus
seiner Wohnung in Köln wo dann
Demonstrationszüge vorbeiging hat immer
wieder auch gesagt dass er sich
tatsächlich bedroht fühlt und hat aber
natürlich auch klar gedacht dass ihnen
das in seiner politischen Arbeit nicht
beeinflussen dass jetzt aber wie gesagt
schon eine erschreckender Plan den es
dort gab der dort gefasst wurde und der
dann durch die Polizei in Koblenz und
die anderen Ermittlungsbehörden eben
aufflog jetzt dort diese Bilder da sehen
wir Elisabeth R in der Mitte mit den
grauen Haaren wir hören auch 75 Jahre
alt soll sie sein nach Angaben der
Bundesanwaltschaft da wird sie eben
jetzt abgeführt die regelführerin die
Frau die offensichtlich Karl Lauterbach
entführen wollte und Deutschland in
bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände versetzen
wollte eine in schwarz gekleidete ältere
Frau mit ja ganz weiß-grauen Haaren also
ist das in diesem Fall eine Frau aus
Sachsen offenbar die dann dort jetzt den
Bundesrichter vorgeführt wird also das
sind die Momente als ja die Ermittlungen
in diesem Fall jetzt erstmal offenbar
zum Erfolg geführt worden der
ermittlungsfall im Jahr geplanten
Entführungsfall Karl Lauterbach
[Musik]